patrick de khost remercie beaucoup
d'être là sur internet
alors vous voulez doubler votre
puissance d'ici 2025 la doubler encore
d'ici 2030 pour qu'on ait une idée de ce
que ça représente là on va vous montrer
un graphique vraiment une progression
presque spectaculaire de votre puissance
de votre énergie là qui est prévue d'ici
est ce que je pourrais plan stratégique
et seulement agressif on sait réaliste
vraiment ceux des costes non c'est un
plan qui est réaliste et d'ailleurs les
années sinon si l'on souligné que ça
c'est un pion cost l'emploi je faisais
moi qui est ambitieux et ambitieux a la
taille de la transition énergétique
mondiale qui est en cours est ambitieux
o'shea et qui est réaliste par rapport à
ce que boralex a fait dans le passé si
on remonte il ya dix ans notre puissance
installée en éolien a été multiplié par
10 sur les dix dernières années alors
aujourd'hui l'entreprise est plus grande
x 2 c'est ambitieux mais c'est
réalisable et j'ai confiance dans le
fait que d'autres
notre équipe va y arriver quand vous
évoquez là pour 2030 entre 10 et 12
gigawatts
c'est ça représente quoi se rappeler
nous là pour nous situer c'est assez
pour répondre aux besoins de combien
ménages par exemple est une production
qui va qui va représenter en termes de
ménage pourrez pas vous deux je vous
donnerai pas le chiffre parce que je
pense que c'est c'est un chiffre que
j'ai pas mais par contre c'est une cette
année a b c d investissement d'une
douzaine de milliards de dollars au
total donc c'est une croissance très
importante de notre organisation et
c'est une part qui resterait quand même
assez faible par rapport à l'ensemble de
la transition énergétique et des besoins
d'investissements que rôle qui seront
nécessaires que ce soit en france que ce
soit aux états unis et que je sois au
canada dans cette transition
oui parce que vous parlez de
positionnement géographique là en ce
moment on voit votre puissance installée
est répartie bon vous voyez là on a sur
le graphique à peu près moitié moitié au
canada et en france
est-ce que vous projetez pour 2030 c'est
d'avoir vraiment le pied dans le marché
américain et pas à peu près là on sera
presque la moitié votre puissance
installée sur le marché américain
pourquoi miser tant que ça sur les états
unis il ya plusieurs choses aux états
unis qui sont importants d'une part les
avis sont en retard en termes de
transition énergétique que ce soit par
rapport à l'europe soit par rapport
au canada c'est un premier sujet il ya
un bassin de population qui est très
important il ya un nouveau président qui
est arrivé et on souhaite vraiment aller
dans cette direction là et boralex a eu
des succès depuis deux ans aux états
unis en particulier dans l'état de new
york
donc on pense que c'est vraiment un
intérêt de se développer aux états unis
dans les prochaines années est aussi bon
en voyait sur le graphique c'est à leur
bon par exemple l union européenne au
royaume uni et cetera votre part
d'énergie produite au québec va
considérablement reculé est-ce que
boralex va rester une entreprise
québécoise avec ses murs ou ses centres
décisionnels ici oui c'est certain ça va
boralex va rester une entreprise
québécoise on va croître au canada et
notre croissance est uniquement prévu
dans les prochaines années au québec au
canada de 40 à 60 % quand même de la
puissance canadienne de la puissance
pardon installé aucun au canada 29
croissant donc c'est quand même
important
puis ça va permettre de développer de
continuer à développer de l'expertisé au
québec d'exporter cette expertise
d'aller rechercher ce qui se fait à
l'étranger donc oui bien sûr boralex
restera une entreprise québécoise et il
n'y a pas qu'une diversification
géographique c'est dans le type
d'énergie vous souhaitez produit aussi
grand changement c'est la part de
l'énergie solaire qui pourrait passer de
9 à 45 % de votre portefeuille pourquoi
miser là-dessus davantage parce que le
solaire ces dernières années a fortement
baissé en termes de coûts et donc est
devenu compétitif avec la production
éolienne qui elle-même a également
baissé donc c'est vraiment les deux
domaines et deux secteurs dans lesquels
la production électrique nouvelle la
plus compétitive
il ya dix ans ce n'était pas le cas
c'est pour ça qu'on a misé sur l'éolien
pendant un certain nombre d'années
mais le solaire est important puis le
solaire est très complémentaire à
l'éolien en termes de revenus tout le
monde sait qu'il ya plus de vent en
hiver et plus de soleil en été
les journées sont plus longues et donc
c'est très complémentaire pour nous et
puis c'est très complémentaires en
termes de risque les riches sont
différents la variation d'une année sur
l'autre du solaire est moins importante
et donc ça veut pas dire que l'éolien
est mauvais ça veut simplement dire que
ça diversifier notre risque et ça nous
amène à une entreprise qui va être plus
stable et plus diversifié bon la demande
énergétique parce qu'elle vous avez de
grandes ambitions l'attend en 10 ans
trouve aujourd'hui
et 2030 la taille de la tempête la
puissance installée de boralex pour être
multipliée par cinq
la demande énergétique est ce qu'elle
est au rendez-vous pour justifier ses
investissements à l'aide ses 10 ans mais
la demande énergétique va augmenter
fortement la demande électrique a
augmenté fortement dans les prochaines
années parce que c'est vraiment une
façon de faire une transition
on le voit au québec où l'énergie
électrique est déjà très utilisé mais
malgré ça dans le plan du gouvernement
il ya une augmentation de 26 % de la
demande électrique pour électrifier les
transports électrifié des processus
industriels et donc il y aura une
demande importante même dans un pays où
l'élite s'est déjà fortement utilisé un
rouge états unis et encore plus de
possibilités parce que par exemple les
ménages se chauffent au gaz
principalement donc une énergie fossile
puis le fait de passer à l'ouest et a
fait une demande également très
importante en plus des industries en
plus du transport
cela dit vous avez quand même des
concurrents mais vous avez de belles
ambitions monsieur de khost reçoivent
bonne chance pour la suite pour les dix
prochaines années
finalement merci d'avoir été là merci
beaucoup
faut voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici rdi